hello everyone and welcome back to binge
battle i am your host mark ellis and
today
boy now usually on this show we talk
about a tv show some actors maybe a
movie occasionally that we're really
excited about that is out in the
zeitgeist currently but today it's gonna
be all the tv shows because we are sort
of previewing sort of prognosticating
the 2022 emmy ceremony coming up this
september now this has been recorded a
few weeks in advance and i want to let
you know that we have two expert
panelists here who are going to give you
their thoughts on what they think should
win what should not win and there might
be some light spoilers in a few of these
heavily nominated programs that being
said i gave you fair warning this is
going to be possibly my favorite binge
battle of the year because we all put so
much into these award shows what is
gonna take top honors best show best
actor best actress what's a little over
hyped all those questions gonna be
answered by two of the all-time greats
and returning champions that we have
here at binge battle also let everybody
know if you want all the latest updates
on what's going on with the 2022 emmy
ceremony or really anything in the world
of television and movies head over to
rottentomatoes.com right now right there
you can get a complete list of all the
nominees for the upcoming emmy ceremony
with that being said it is my great
honor to welcome two binge battle a
returning favorite you know her as a
correspondent from everything from
rotten tomatoes here to e news and she
also happens to
rescue wolves i believe and she also
knows where the best burger in los
angeles is it's the one and only naz
perez nas welcome back thank you so much
i'm so excited for this this is gonna be
fun so do you get hyped up for the award
shows from a competitive standpoint or
do you just enjoy watching the red
carpet stuff the glitz and the glamour
of it well of course i love any fashion
um that i get to see on a red carpet but
no for me it's just about all it's about
celebrating all the television and art
that entertained us throughout the year
and especially in the last couple years
i feel like we've all had it a little
bit rough um and we've all been watching
a little bit more tv which to me makes
the emmy's race that much more exciting
because people are so invested so
there's naz perez and her opponent today
is also another dear friend of mine you
know her as a tv host for a number of
outlets including her own endeavor the
world girls it is roxy stryer the star
of the film always load making its run
in the film festival circuit roxy i do
want to get to the emmys but first of
all how exciting was it
to be at the always level of premiere
and have everybody watching you on the
big screen i was there and i just i
don't know if i would have been nervous
or excited what was that elixir like it
was amazing mark i had never seen the
movie so it could have just been trash
and luckily it was not uh and so having
people there like you i was like okay
if it's going to suck then i'm not going
to see him afterwards he's going to run
out and that's how how i'll know and
then afterwards everybody stuck around
and everybody was saying how good it was
and i can tell your lying face and that
was the truthful face so it was really
incredible and i also just wanted to let
you guys know that um i might not rescue
wolves but i did rescue an era an
earring from the drain today that got
dropped
so i'm also kind of a hero uh and i just
think that's important to know going
into this also true jersey girl fashion
and i am so excited to be here with roxy
like you have no idea
that's roxy i am so excited to have both
y'all here and roxy i know what a
competitive person you are in your
everyday life and particularly as we get
into nfl season do you watch the emmys
like sitting on the edge of your seat do
you have your picks ready are you
rooting actively for shows this is
definitely by far and away my favorite
night of television of the year i know
that some people are down on award shows
i don't care what they say the emmys are
like my it is my super bowl even though
the super bowl is also my super bowl i
love the emmys i dream of being at the
emmys one day i dream of my acceptance
speech i'm that girl who didn't ever
design her wedding dress and has
designed every single emmy's outfit i
could ever wear like i i knew these
people so hard they had to work their
butts off to get there every single one
of them and it's just such an incredible
night and maybe awards shouldn't matter
but in this household which is a
household of one they certainly do
wow you see what happens to these
patriots fans folks they get so spoiled
going to nine super bowls in the last
two decades now they call the emmys
their super bowl well we are gonna get
going with the super bowl of binge
battle for this year anyway at least
it's the emmy prediction show i am so
excited to hear y'all's picks to hear
what you think may be a little overrated
what's underrated who should be winning
and so here is how the show works each
of you is going to be doing competitive
verbal debate through at least four
rounds we do have a fifth round prepared
in case we need a tie breaker you get a
minute opening salvo you have a 30
second rebuttal and finally you have a
10 to 15 second closing statement to
drop the mic on your argument and then
it is up to me your judge jury and judy
to give a point to who i think made the
best argument or maybe just who i agree
with let's be honest so we're gonna get
it kicked off here with round number one
roxy we're starting with you and the
question is thus what is the best drama
series what should be winning and i say
this with a qualifier because both of
our contestants as well as me and
probably everybody watching is rooting
for and thinks the show severance should
be winning it was brilliant maybe if we
have time at the end we can gush about
severance but so severance is dq'd from
today only because we think it's gonna
win but what other show if severance
didn't exist should be taking top honors
in best drama series this might be the
best year of television we've ever had
but putting severance aside there is
another show that is truly excellent
that i have no business loving as much
as i do and that is succession let's
talk about a show that we should all
hate with a bunch of rich white people
just complaining about their problems
that i cannot relate to like never have
i been watching succession and been like
yup i feel you i understand what you're
going through that's never one time
happened to me and yet every single week
when it comes on
the world must stop because i have to be
watching this show i don't know why it's
so good i don't understand why we all
love it the way we do could it be the
brilliant writing the incredible acting
or the fact that it is just so far out
of the realm of my world that it takes
me to like escapism television maybe
that i've never seen a show that just
like is such a hard hitter like this
where you could win in
this show could take home all of the
emmys and nobody would be surprised not
just for best drama but for pretty much
every person who's ever been on screen
in this show they all have noms and
because of that not only do i think that
this could win but i think that very
likely it should win
yeah i don't care if it wins or loses
but i want to get this ceremony over
with so that we get season four
sooner rather than later let's go to naz
perez who is going to be arguing for
something that is not severance and it's
not succession what do you got naz
well i'm gonna go with the biggest
surprise of the entire tv season which i
think we can all agree is squid game
squid game is like the little show that
could the creator and director huan dong
hyuk actually said that it took him like
10 years to make the show and ended up
being netflix's most watched series ever
it has 14 nominations it's the first
non-english series um to even be
nominated in this category and if you
guys think about it if you remember the
oscars when parasite won which was the
first non-english film to win no actors
were even nominated and i know that
that's the oscars and this is the emmys
but listen it's also just hollywood and
i think that this show if it were to win
in any category it's gonna win in best
drama series for overall achievement i
think succession is more likely to win
in like the acting categories i mean
this show out of any other series
nominated in outstanding drama has the
most captivating storyline ever it's
literally a social commentary on
feminism on ageism on classism i mean
the fact i mean the fact that it made
red light green light like horrific
should admit should we should be giving
it a war just for that reason also the
performances were outstanding lee
jung-jae chun ho young took home the sag
awards for it lee's taken other acting
awards for it but i just think that
squid game all in all has the most
captivating storyline and really just
shocked the world as opposed to any
other shows nominated in this category
yeah i think i was right there with a
lot of people when i saw a red light
green light i'm like oh i can play this
and then i two minutes later i'm like
okay never mind my bad get me out of
here uh roxy let's go back to you talk
about succession and maybe why you think
that should get the nod over squid game
so what i'm not gonna do is sit here and
tell you that squid game isn't
incredible because it absolutely is that
is one of the best shows of the year but
i do think that one of the reasons we're
talking about it is because it was so
surprising it was just such a
none of us were looking forward to it
and it wasn't on anybody's radar and so
i think that it really shocked the world
and we weren't ready for it and that's
why people were saying you've never seen
something like that succession had a lot
more work to do because it was coming
off of two of the most talked about
television
seasons ever people were obsessed with
this show and it had a lot of heavy
lifting to do and the fact that it got
even better in this season than it was
previously was like how did you manage
to one-up yourself uh i i can't wait to
see in what world and what raps we see
next season like if they just keep going
on this trajectory it could be one of
the best shows of all time so that's why
i think it edges out squid game by
slight margin
careening towards goat status uh let's
go back to nas naz why do you think
squid game maybe edges out succession
well i think because succession already
won outstanding drama series in 2020 um
i think it would be deserving if it won
this year but i think the season that it
won for was actually better than season
three i kind of disagree with you roxy
there and i i truly feel like the
television academy likes to award
freshmen series and series that like
really spark a global conversation which
is why i really feel like squid game
would win over succession um but i agree
with you roxy i think succession is like
one of the greatest of all time it's one
of my favorite shows and i even listened
to the theme song on the way to see my
family sometimes i think netflix takes
this category again they won for the
crown last year and i think uh i think
squid game would take it this year if
severance didn't sounds like we need to
have cameras following nasa's family
reunions because if that's the music
you're planning to get
pumped up i think we need to see what
goes on at thanksgiving uh so many
follow-ups for that so many questions
but yes i'll ask you later
you get to you get to have the first mic
drop of the day what is your closing
statement stumping for succession when
you're a show that has 25 emmy
nominations how do you look past that
the fact that it has more emmy
nominations than any other show this
year that it did win for last season and
it's not just riding on the coattails of
last season they were original this year
they gave us new fresh material that we
were not expecting and still we're
managing to leave us on a cliffhanger
that's going to leave everybody coming
back for more so i think it's got to be
succession just because of how many
incredible elements make up that one
show all right and naz perez the last
word in round one goes to you well i'll
say there are a lot of elements in squid
game too i mean they've racked up so
many awards for stunts i mean story
costume
uh acting so i feel like a lot of the
elements are there with squid game too
but the difference between a squid game
and a succession is i really squid game
is not just an emmy nominee like
succession or even severances and it's
not just a tv show it's a cultural
phenomenon it honestly should be in the
dystopian hall of fame i mean we're even
getting like a reality spin-off show
squid game the challenge where like
they're going to give off like 456
million dollars to like contestants
found around the world and i just think
if you go to like the deepest off the
grid nooks and crannies of the world
chances are people there have probably
not seen or heard of succession in
severance but chances are they've
probably heard of squid game and for
that reason and for the global
conversation it's created i think that
it's gonna be it's gonna take
outstanding drama series just for that
achievement alone all right well first
things first uh sign me up for the
reality show based on squid game i will
compete in that um and i'll say this
no
hey i'm gonna need a teammate from but
one of y'all's gonna have to be my my
partner here like that when you were a
kid you wanted to be on double dare and
now as an adult you want to be on squid
game just guys
um when i'm thinking about the these two
shows in particular it's an interesting
dichotomy because roxy you make an
excellent point about succession how do
you follow the cliffhanger that we got
with an excellent season two i think
that season three was probably the best
one thus far because i think that they
got the tone between
a satire parody but also like really
intense drama perfectly nailed this time
around but squid game like nas says was
more than just a a little show that
could it was more than just a surprise
it was a cultural phenomenon to the
point where netflix said that in his
first 28 days uh 1.6 billion hours of
viewing time were dedicated by viewers
to squid game which shatters the record
of bridgerton which was only like 600
million hours previously so i think that
there really is something here and the
other thing i'll say is that i don't
think if succession was going against
severance that succession would have a
chance i think squid game does have a
chance i think that might be the one
that has a chance over severance and so
great arguments all around i'm gonna
lean towards the person who really uh
sort of embodies the succession music
naz perez with her pick of squid game in
round one and naz is on the board first
it is one to nothing fair an
embarrassment of riches that we have to
debate here on binge battles we head
into round number two naz kicks us off
with our topic the best actor and
actress in a drama series going on
riding on the coattails of roxy's
amazing argument on succession i think
that the three of us can agree that the
fact that brian cox does not have an
emmy for playing logan roy is like
actually criminal because his
performance is towering he is ruthless
he is intense he is cantankerous he
plays this man that deep deep deep down
loves his children even through all of
those feelings and i think only brian
cox could really could really pull off
that nuance um you said it before roxy
like this show has 25 emmy nominations
they broke a record this year for
getting 14 nods in the acting categories
this is an acting show and leading the
pack is mr brian cox and then for best
actress in a drama series i'm gonna go
with zendaya you know zendaya became the
youngest uh female to win in this
category at 24 years old in 2020 and a
lot of people honestly underestimated
zendaya for it because she was this
disney child star and she is so raw as
this character rue and in this last
season of euphoria she goes on a bender
and really does all these unhinged and
dangerous things and i feel like this
season of euphoria was really a
container
to showcase all of the talents that
zendaya has and really really brings to
to this show 19 million people watched
euphoria this season and the average
percentage from season one to season two
like per episode viewership was up 100
meaning that awareness and of this show
is just massive meaning more emmy voters
have watched it and her performance
which is why i think she'll take it
again this year like she did in 2020
yeah she was a she was a bit of a
surprise winner in in 2020 but now you
have brian cox who again it's it's it
sounds like it should be headline news
that he has not won an emmy for playing
logan roya which is shocking we go to
roxy streier to counter with your best
actor and actress for a drama series so
we've switched positions a little bit
here because while you might be taking a
succession person i'm taking a squid
game person so it may help me that you
just won in this previous argument
listen uh lee jeong-jae is like just
truly the reason that this show works i
can't believe that we took a show and we
showed it to an american audience and
this show is in a foreign language and
people were still captivated captivated
by him
not because that shouldn't be the way it
always is but just because that's never
the way that it is we are a bunch of
people who like to watch american
content in this country and the people
that step outside of that boundary often
times
they're met with uh pushback saying i
don't want to watch listen to uh and
dubs or subtitles
but somehow someway this show was so
great that even the people that fight
against foreign language shows were like
no this show is incredible and it's
because of one reason it's what the
whole show centers around we are rooting
for a character that i don't even know
if he's a good dude probably not based
on the things that we saw but you're
still rooting for him the emotion in his
face the arc that he goes through the
fact that even towards the end when he
is messing with some of our favorite
characters and working so that they
might end up dying off you're still like
i still want you to live even if it
means that the elderly die i
damn me to wherever i'm going i still
want you to live this man is such a
brilliant actor that he made not just
this country but the entire world fall
in love with him even if he's not the
greatest guy and that's incredible uh
and then on the other side of things wow
do i can i not talk enough about laura
lenny uh i think that
ozark also doesn't work without her i
think she is everything that people
wanted skyler to be in breaking bad and
what made people so mad about that show
i think that she is so nuanced and like
maybe the world's worst human being and
yet she is a mother that you want to see
protect everybody uh and the way that
she does this is i have no idea like how
she is manipulating me to still say is
she a good person do i like her it's all
in the face and whatever she's doing
with her face
it's so working uh plus it's the final
season she never won for ozark that is
ridiculous it's the last chance to give
it to her so li jongjae and laura linney
for the win i i i like the where y'all
are going where it's like you have sort
of two legacy actors and you're like
what no they they need to wait how can
they not have won for this yet and then
you have two more newcomers at least two
american audiences so back to you naz uh
summit for zendaya and brian cox like
you were saying mark a lot of people
don't know that brian cox does not have
an emmy for this um he was actually the
first succession cast member to win an
acting award i believe at the golden
globes but jeremy strong his like number
one boy actually uh took home the emmy
for this last time they were both in
this category together i think it's safe
to say like brian cox just deserves this
for this past season there's a dinner
scene between jeremy strong and logan
roy um in the penultimate episode that
is just so absorbing and the
intimidation that brian is able to exude
the stillness that he has in the
character he almost feels like a great
white shark in the water and i don't
know many actors to make you feel that
way through the screen i mean you're not
even like sitting next to him it was
that final scene in succession i'm
trying to figure out ways to say it
without really spoiling it i just
believe because of that scene and and
what logan roy was able to do i feel
like he's gonna come out on top this is
laura linney's last chance and laura
linney is outstanding roxy she has
won every emmy for every performance
that she's been nominated for and sadly
i think this is going to be the first
time that she's nominated for a show and
doesn't take home an award for it and
the reason why i say that is because i
was listening to um a podcast on one of
you know one of these outlets that we
all listen to i think it was gold derby
wendy the character that laura lenny
plays is kind of like walter white and i
don't think there's a certain group of
emmy voters that don't really take to
cold women roles like that and for that
reason i don't think laura linney would
win i think zendaya would take it over
her um even though i think laura linney
is super deserving i just i love the
amount of effort and research you all
put into
this episode it warms my heart that
people care hi everybody watching let's
go back to roxy for your rebuttal here
and supporting both squid game and ozark
i think when it comes to brian cox
i just don't know that he is better than
jeremy strong i think they are equal and
that might not be fair to them but when
i am when they're both nominated and i'm
thinking about who deserves to win i
can't pick one of them over the other i
just can't because i think that they're
both so powerful
jeremy has a lot of weirder stuff to do
uh and brian cox had to have an sti this
season so you know we've got to give it
to him for that that was that seemed
like a whole different player of its own
but i just don't know that he he is the
best on the show even though he is so
incredible and i also feel like i'm just
so tired of watching really old rich
white men screaming and that is like i
see it on the news all the time so when
i turn him on sometimes i'm like oh my
god brian again for sure again and it's
accurate but i just don't know that i'm
in the mood for it all the time you
might be right about laura linney that
they might not give it to her because
they don't like cold women but i'm going
to sit here and defend all of the cold
women because there are more cold men
and they give it to the cole men all of
the time
zendaya is so young she is so powerful
she is an absolute star but she did win
for this role already and there will be
more years of euphoria that she can win
for as well as opposed to laura linney
who this is her last year and maybe her
best performance and a performance that
is is so different than zendaya who is a
drug addict on the show that gives you
so much to play with uh as opposed to
laura linney's character where i feel
like wendy is something she created she
just straight up
from her own brain was like this is what
i want to bring to the screen
uh and for li jongjae i we already know
that square game won the argument so he
made that show that one argument
and we go back to naz perez now for your
closing statement here in round two it's
a jam-packed round two we're talking
about four incredible talents naz what's
the final statement the twitter
adoration that this this man has gotten
for cursing and saying oh f off um the
fact that his first and only emmy was in
2001 and this logan roy in succession is
perhaps the role of his career i really
see the tv academy giving it to him this
season um because like you said
you feel like him and jeremy are kind of
neck to neck but jeremy has won already
i feel like it's sort of brian cox's
time because this is really like a
legendary role i love laura linney too
roxy and so in my head i'm like yeah i
can see why and just so everyone
watching knows everyone has always been
wrong about best actress in a drama
series category every time someone
thinks it's this person another person
wins so that's what's really really fun
about the emmys in this category
specifically so laura could definitely
take it but i just think zendaya's kind
of like going up against beyonce like
you just don't bet your chips you don't
go to vegas and bet against zendaya
she's nominated four times this season
and um one for the series one in this
category and two for original song and
lyrics that she contributed to the show
and i think that is just proof enough of
how much the academy loves zendaya and
why she will be taking home the enemy in
this category nice little nugget from
naz is that if you're making your
predictions at home maybe you don't bet
laura winnie or sentai yes there you go
surprise everyone uh roxy you get the
final statement here in round number two
i think with laura lenny uh like you
said we never know the direction we're
going in so all i can do is go with my
heart and say who i think really
deserves to win it and the fact that she
was such a different character season
one as opposed to the finale of this and
the fact that we don't think that ozark
is going to win best show and we don't
think that grayson bateman in fact we
don't think he's going to win best actor
the fact that we that none of those
things are going to win and ozark was
such a massive hit for them i think it's
got to go to her and the fact that li
zhang jae came into every single
person's household and said and burst
the door open and said you will respect
me you will pay attention to me you will
watch me i think that
if you are a betting person which you
you shouldn't be says my therapist than
just
but these are some some pretty good
horses to back if you are a betting
person i don't know if we condone
gambling on the show as indicated it is
a family program so take it for what you
will but you know you're talking about a
couple shows that really are not
necessarily for the whole family and
when you look at these two
sets of performers what strikes me again
is that you have like okay this might be
the last chance for someone like laura
linney brian cox is number one for this
role that we just assume he's won every
time for i i love nasa's point that
brian cox is so cantankerous in the show
it's a great word for a guy who also
somehow can be doing voice over on a
commercial and make me really hungry for
a hamburger so i look at roxy and i do
love the point that roxy made when it
comes to a political race sometimes you
look at two different candidates from
the same party and you say that they're
going to be stealing votes from each
other maybe that could happen with
jeremy strong and brian cox maybe that's
already what's happened and so i think
the key factor for me the deciding
factor here is laura linney in ozark i
think that above all the other ones that
we mentioned today laura winnie is the
one who just gave such a riveting
performance because at the same time we
didn't know how that show was going to
end and so to be on the edge of our seat
watching her and her many faces and
watching the events unfold i think that
that was just such captivating tv and
she was at the center of all of it so i
give roxy the point here in round two
and you know these are some of the
arguments and then also who i think is
gonna win but like again i would take
roxy and naz's words to the bank more
than i would take my decision to the
bank if i can just absolve myself of any
financial loss that the viewer may incur
so we move to round three it's a tied
ball game one to one and our next round
is gonna be a fun topic because what's
the overhyped series what's the
overhyped series that got nominated and
you're like oh rip really okay you know
it doesn't it's interesting you hat you
hate it or you think it's bad but it's
just like maybe it's a little too
overhyped for you
starting with naz perez i probably
shouldn't have picked this knowing that
mark ellis hosts this show
uh-oh
i'm definitely shooting myself in the
foot
but my overhyped series is saturday
night live
snl just everywhere knows has a
five-year winning streak and they have
benefited from a change that was made in
the emmy categories in 2015
when variety series was split into
variety talk series and variety sketch
series and because of that snl barely
goes up against anything i think they
have like 305 nominations 81 emmys
overall they're only nominated this year
up against a black lady sketch show and
i just feel like it's time for another
another sketch variety series to shine i
love snl it's always going to be a
classic i want bow and yang to win i
think it's always going to be iconic i
love nbc universal they help me pay rent
i do love snl i do think it's overhyped
and just to throw in a little more
controversy i think kim kardashian saved
this last season of snl i'm sorry but i
do
wow okay so spicy taste from naz perez
so let's move over to roxy streyer's
side of the street and see what do you
think is the most over hyped series that
was nominated so i watch a lot of
television if you if you can't guess
already uh and sometimes i do this thing
that i call rocking the high low and one
of the shows that i put on the low end
of that is a show that consistently gets
nominated at the emmys and i'm baffled
by it and that is flight attendant
listen i like this show it is a guilty
pleasure of mine but make no mistake
that's what it is a guilty pleasure this
is not a great show it is a show that i
really enjoy watching and it is so fun
to do so
but
an emmy nominated show last year it was
nominated for outstanding comedy series
what are we talking about this year
she's nominated this is a show that's
been nominated
multiple times uh
what
who's
who's paying who on this because i i'm
just i'm shocked it was like when emily
in paris was nominated what are we
talking about what are we talking about
flight attendant you're you're so fun to
watch but are you the greatest show
is this the greatest performance what
what
no no no no people just like her a lot
no no this is not no no i am impressed
and stunned at your ability to separate
guilty pleasures from just stuff you
actually think is great because you're
being judged by a guy who still thinks
rocky iv is like the best movie of the
80s so
maybe i have some soul searching to do
or maybe rocky iv is just that good in
the meantime let's go back to naz perez
for your most over hyped show snl the
the almost 50-year legacy sketch show
well mark you and i are from the same
camp because i think roxy that it that
is an incredible gift you have to be
able to separate the two because i i
skewed towards loving rotten movies and
shows
um
i think instead of arguing more for snl
because i believe that i made most of my
points and i don't know if i have any
more i do just want to do a little
rebuttal if i may on kaylee cuoco and
the flight attendant because this year i
don't think the series was nominated
kaylee cuoco is and i actually think she
shines as a hot mess i think her ability
to blend comedy and drama is actually
really hard to do and i think her
performance is fun to watch i think the
tone is interesting i think it's a
different tone of a show that we that
actually isn't really on tv right now i
mean i love romance i love murder i love
travel
um and so i love all those things and so
and just because kaylee cuoco was never
really recognized for a big bang theory
i actually really like um to see her
getting recognized for this show that
she put her heart and soul into
um and that she helped create
all right so back to you roxy you can
continue to support uh kaylee and flight
attendant as being over hyped or you can
maybe stump for snl a little bit it's
fielder's choice i love kaylee cuoco
don't get me wrong but it would be like
nominating leighton meester for gossip
girl just it's just not how it's done as
an emmy's purist you just don't take a
show
and she's great she's fitting the
character perfect nobody else could play
the role better it's just not an emmy
worthy role which is why if she won i
would flip a table for snl i want to
talk about it briefly because was it the
best season of snl ever of course not
but it's still snl which means that
there are still such incredible moments
on the show i'm with you about kim k i
think that she is a she is a rock star
and her opening monologue and then
watching what she did to do all that on
the car on the kardashian show was
incredible but it's not just her it's uh
simula you and it's paul rudd and it's
owen wilson it's jason sedakis and it's
saying goodbye to some of our favorite
people like pete davidson and kate
mckinnon and eddie bryant uh and kyle
mooney and it's and it's all of the uh
people and things that we love even when
there are down moments it's still the
greatest sketch show
and the reason it's getting all the wins
is because there isn't anything that's
as good
all right back to nas perez for the
final word here with the over-hyped
series i 100 agree with a lot of what
you're saying about snl and yeah the
fact that we get to say bye to p and k
and 80 and kyle was it definitely made
it like a very special season and and in
no way do i not think it's like
absolutely unbelievable i just think
like we know it's been unbelievable like
for years like we know and there's other
incredible things out there too and so
that's why i consider it overhyped i
think it should get hyped but i think
this year it's just kind of over hyped
and i would just like to see something
else when i would like to see shows like
i believe it's pronounced z-way i don't
want to um say
but she her show on show time like so
good why why isn't why isn't that you
know what i mean
like getting more recognition i don't
know i feel like more people talk about
snl than they do about those shows and
so for that reason i stick with snl as
being overhyped all right last word in
round three goes to roxy streier and a
leading point is at stake
i'm completely with you on that by the
way and there are other shows that
should be hyped um
none of those shows are flight attendant
the flight attendant isn't over hyped
flight attendant is being hyped and i
don't understand
i love 90210 i loved me some oc i love
all these show are they emmy nominated
worthy like because this show getting
nominated is one of the weirdest things
that the emmys has ever done two years
in a row she's been nominated it being
nominated last year as a show but this
show should not be nominated
can we earmark this round this might
have been my favorite round just to sit
back and watch like i forgot that i had
the judges at some point just because
nas makes an excellent point here
because everybody should be watching a
black lady sketch show if you're not it
is fall down funny and snl it's it is a
legacy nomination it's a legacy it's a
legacy show it's been going for 50 years
and that in itself is an accomplishment
and you know to be fair i don't
necessarily tune into snl all that much
anymore but i also work saturday nights
for the for the flight attendant i
it's hbo max
has been having a rough month we can say
and to know that this show was on there
i did breeze by it occasionally and so i
think that the way i judged this round
is just it was so enjoyable naz makes
great points but it was so enjoyable to
watch a roxie torn amongst herself she
loves this chauffeur
and she's going to flip a table it's
like saying i love the patriots but if
they get into the playoffs it's not fair
it's just so fun and so i i have to give
roxy the point for despite her affinity
for the program saying it's overhyped
man really you you sold your soul but
you got a point out of it so roxanna did
sell my soul i feel soulless now but i'm
still ready in here hey well you you you
may be soulless but you have a
two-to-one lead and i recommend the show
you should watch it it's a good time
came here to win and roxy currently has
the lead as we head into round number
four and that is the biggest surprise
nomination and y'all can take this any
way you want that's the topic biggest
surprise is it a good surprise is it a
bad surprise we are going to start with
roxy's dryer when i first watched abbott
elementary nobody was watching it it was
on in real time and it was kind of one
of those things you look left and you
look right and you're like why is nobody
talking about this show this show is so
funny this is the next parks and rec it
is hysterical and i think it's because
there's no
massive celebrities on the show uh
quinta the creator has not had a laundry
list of other shows that she's worked on
it just kind of was this like random
show that i came across
on abc and was like wow nobody's talking
about this but it is incredible and the
fact that the emmys caught wind of that
i was just kind of surprised with the
fact that she's nominated and the show
is dominated is such a pleasant surprise
because this isn't a a
big hbo or showtime comedy this is a
we're going back to the basics here this
is an abc show we're going with a
classic network sitcom and it is uh one
of those the office style break the
fourth wall talk to the camera and it's
hysterical and it deserves all of this
love i just can't believe it's getting
it yeah it is a very very entertaining
show um let's go to naz perez here for
your biggest surprise nomination and
again take it any way you want yes so um
first of all roxy i love that you
brought up abbott elementary um because
yes it's holding it down for broadcast
and since this is us didn't really get
loved the season around i was really
happy to see that i loved the white
lotus the white lotus was my favorite
show of last year which is saying so
much because we are all talking about so
much i knew the white lotus was going to
get nominated i didn't think it was
going to have 20 nominations so it was
like the biggest pleasant surprise for
me um because i felt like i had to tell
so many about my friends about it so i
was like oh my god thank god like
everyone and the emmys is really like
into the show because if you guys think
about it it's now been over a year since
um the creator and writer mike white
made this show it was the surprise head
of the summer and the fact that it has
five acting nominations under um best
actress in limited series is like crazy
momentum to have after a year from
coming out i mean you got jennifer
coolidge who i believe got her first i
mean you know she's gonna get her first
emmy ever because of this and uh murray
bartlett like the cast was so good
connie britton sydney sweeney one of two
nominations she's like such a breakout
star alexandra d'addario like it was
just
it's such a satire um for rich people
today and the way that the
the way that the guests of the hotel and
the and the um
what's the word the guest of the hotel
and this
the staff of the hotel
interact
like it was just
that's it was just a social commentary
on class society done in such a funny
way in so many different tones the music
is a character in the show the white
lotus really just came out of no out of
nowhere like a white lotus popped out of
the snow and i um was so pleasantly
surprised to see it get 20 nominations
yeah and i i did watch it i'm not sure
if i finished white lotus i but i murray
bartlett's saying of pineapple it just
got stuck in my head like the pineapple
sweet i think is what they're trying to
get into anyway it's pineapple sweet
it's still back in the gray matter
somewhere uh let's go back to roxy
because you made some great points about
abbott elementary it's a network show
and these days we're surprised that it's
a network show getting nominated yeah i
i i think that i agree with every single
thing
that nas said about white lotus and
that's the thing that i'm gonna flip on
her for a second because this show had a
ton of stars in it it had a lot of
people we know and a lot of people
working on this show that are really
successful and really famous and that's
why it was a killer show i loved this
show was not surprised when everybody
else loved it too and when the emmys
loved it this is a show that is a mike
white show he was on uh worked on freaks
and geeks and wrote for dawson's creek
he wrote school of rock he wrote nacho
libre he wrote pitch perfect three he's
got a lot of stuff under his belt as
opposed to quinta who
she was on black lady sketch show but
she's not she hasn't created something
that we're like oh we all know her from
this and there she did she came out as
like this powerhouse in the
entertainment industry on this show that
she created and is starring in that is i
think gonna run for the next eight years
i mean she set up a whole show that can
could take over a decade worth of emmy
nominations and television and so i
think that these shows are equally great
in their own ways just with the white
lotus with jennifer coolidge and
alexander daddario and connie britton
and sydney sweeney and all the people
we're naming it's not surprising these
these big celebrities are getting
nominations it's surprising that quinta
and abbott elementary have seven
nominations at the emmys just shocking
all right let's go back to naz who was
shocked or at least surprised about
white lotus
yeah i mean i think
for sure there's like no argument there
and i i believe kinta actually broke a
couple records too with a lot of her
nominations which i'm like so happy and
applied to see it happen but even but
you mentioned like big stars it's like
isn't it surprising that jennifer
coolidge doesn't have an emmy like yeah
yeah like this show is sort of and and i
don't think i actually don't wouldn't
say that this show had like i don't want
to say the word biggest stars you know
what i mean because i i think a lot of
you know sydney sweeney's a breakout
natasha rothwell never got nominated
from insecure um and she deserves all
the emmy love in the world and her and
jennifer coolidge just go toe-to-toe in
so many scenes and that's surprising to
me that she's like finally not like
surprising but i'm kind of like
pleasantly surprised that she's finally
getting recognized alexandra daddario
like murray bartlett all he's been
acting forever but this was also his
breakout role and i just feel like the
white lotus did such a good job of
telling multiple stories and weaving
them together in just six episodes which
i think is really its appeal it was like
an easy binge it blends comedy it blends
drama it blends thrills there's like a
murder in it um i don't know i like i
said i
for me it's not the most surprising i
think we're kind of doing we're arguing
different things you're you're arguing
most surprising mine was like i was most
pleasantly surprised to see it get all
this love and all these stars finally
sort of get their flowers so to speak
through this show that really came out
of nowhere
i just i want nasa's description on the
next season of white lotus it's like
there's some comedy there's some drama
there's a murder it's great
um let's go to roxy to drop the mic with
her final statement yeah now this is
completely correct her show is super
deserving uh her show the show that
she's talking about lotus but when i
just think about even if you just hear
show on hbo max miniseries on hbo max
gets a ton of nominations with a huge
director writer behind it and a bunch of
stars who you have seen a bajillion
times
that is not like
what no way but when you hear it's 2022
you're not gonna recognize any of these
names attached to this project but this
abc show that is in its first year will
make you laugh your butt off to the
point that it got seven emmy nominations
it's like wow
who who would have guessed
not me and something crazy about this
show is that they gave a lot of their
marketing budget to inner city schools
in philadelphia so they had like no
marketing behind them and so that's why
this show was such a slow burn so the
fact that they had such a limited
marketing budget because of what they
did with their finances and everybody's
still talking about it at the emmys
that's pretty cool
all right let me check with the judges
is that illegal tugging at my
heartstrings right there
drop there's a season two for white
lotus even though it's a limited series
uh nasa i'll give you a double mic drop
if you would like to add anything else
no no it's okay i think this category is
funny though because i think i was just
more thinking of what i was pleasantly
surprised by but like
yeah obviously i love abbott elementary
and i didn't know that roxy that's so
cool
that's sick well if i have to make a
decision here i'm going to i'm going to
say it like this let's let's not exactly
over hype how famous everybody in white
lotus is
it's it's not like you know you have
like brad pitt it's like zendaya is in
the show it's not kim
kardashian what i was trying yeah that's
what i was trying to articulate kim
kardashian coolidge is my a-list
celebrity okay i've been trying to work
on that voice
it's it's got a lot of people that
you're like oh i like them it is what i
would say white lotus but i mean again
it's it's such an odd time in 2022 where
hbo is is the the powerhouse that's
cranking out show after show that always
you just expect nominations and so i do
think that it is a surprise that white
lotus got as much love as it did simply
because you are going up against your
it's sort of like you don't want to
cannibalize your own network and there's
so many great hbo shows the fact that
white lotus emerged from the pack along
with succession and and stuff like that
is impressive but you know roxy was just
hammering the points home about abbott
elementary and and and this the little
show that could it's on a network abc
but again abc doesn't necessarily mean
what it did 10 20 even five years ago as
far as a network pedigree goes none of
the networks do in terms of the emmys so
i do think that abbott elementary would
be the biggest surprise nomination at
least the big er and so i give roxy the
point here so roxy gets the win but
we ought congratulations roxy you are a
champion but before roxy gets to the
super bowl enjoy her flowers
you won the super bowl but because we
didn't have time for a tie break around
it and roxy ended up winning three to
one i do want to give y'all just maybe
30 seconds each to give us each an
underrated series that you think
deserves recognition that that's what
would have been our tiebreaker round and
and i just want to hear the shows that
you all think maybe more people should
be paying attention to maybe the emmys
should be paying more attention to so
nas i want to start with you it was a
tough loss today you fought valiantly
you made a bunch of great points what is
your underrated series that deserves
more love thank you it is an honor just
to be invited to play and speak um
because we all love tv um i gotta talk
about insecure you know issa rae is
nominated this year but i feel like this
show just flew under the emmy's radar
and did not get the recognition that it
deserved insecure was so groundbreaking
in so many different ways it showed us a
different part of l.a had like a mainly
black cast it was so hilarious that
really was the little show that could
the fact that issa rae
became just like this breakout like she
she had awkward black girl on like
youtube and it turned into like this
huge show with a massive fandom on hbo
um and the fact that it was only ever
nominated as a series in 2020 just it
really makes me sad um like i was saying
earlier natasha rothwell happy to see
her recognized for white lotus i wish
her work on this show yvonne ogie um
should have been sort of recognized more
for insecure
i think this last season really just
stuck the landing it's a show that dives
deep into friendships into race into
family um and i i just think this last
season was so incredible it ended so
perfectly that um
i i think it's an under the radar show
that people should pay more attention to
i got turned on to it in season two and
it became appointment doing for me and
the fact that
she gets picked up at the airport at the
the opening of the final season and then
we're we're broken up by the time we get
home it's like that what a baller play
by issa and again just a testament to
what you can do if you have enough
creative vision and enough willpower to
get it done uh roxy you had enough
willpower to get the win here today in
your super bowl what is an underrated
series that you think deserves more emmy
love well i also agree with insecure
that gets the win for this this for me
because i'm so with you that it's a
crime that show was not nominated more
often i don't get what happened there
and i hope that isa ends up winning for
lead actors in a comedy series she
deserves it this year uh but for me the
show that i am really confused about at
the emmys every year and there's there's
some funny business going on with this
one clearly is yellowstone yellowstone
is a show that is watched by
14 million viewers a week now those num
that doesn't mean what it used to mean
like i know that big numbers used to be
bigger than that but in a world where
there are 900 original series a year
that you can watch that are scripted or
over a thousand or something 14 million
viewers a week is insane that's on
average not only does the show get
snubbed but kevin costner and kelly
riley both continue to get snubbed the
the actress kelly riley that plays this
character beth it's my my favorite
character on television period uh and
she's unbelievable i think that's why
the kaylee cuoco nomination bothers me
so much because it's like
but then there's kelly riley who's just
like snubbed after snub this has only
ever been nominated for one
at me ever
uh in in all of the years and none this
year it is three spin-offs or three
plants been asked one with helen mirren
and harrison ford like what are we
talking about that this show that is a
powerhouse gets completely shut out
every year with a-list celebrities uh an
incredible um theme to it it's basically
like like succession but
cowboys and and spin off my first
spin-off
who whose serial did they piss him
because somebody's somebody's not happy
with yellowstone yeah i love yellowstone
too and i i'm not gonna take up time but
everything you said is so correct and i
hope roxy that in the same way where
shit's creek started to get recognition
towards the end um i hope that kind of
happens for yellowstone eventually yeah
fingers crossed yeah all right well then
i mean this is going to end on a weird
note because every time i try to watch
yellowstone i end up falling asleep
within 30 minutes so i'm not i'm not
sure insecure does it for me yellowstone
not there i'll give it another shot for
roxy and it's happening i would have won
this category is what you're saying
yes i mean
we're lucky we didn't go to overtime um
but that was such a well-played match by
both of y'all here at binge battle uh
honoring and celebrating and just
getting everybody hyped for the 2022
emmy ceremony this september i want to
remind everybody you can head to
rottentomatoes.com for the list of
nominees in every category for the 2022
emmys and then rottentomatoes.com it's
also just great hub to have for all your
tv movies everything that's going on in
the world all your tomato meter scores
all your audience score in the late
breaking news uh that's the website to
bookmark people bookmark websites
anymore i'm told that some people do so
bookmark that website uh roxie striar
you can follow her at roxy stryer across
social media platforms and check out her
endeavors on the world girls where they
give new cool things a try and naz perez
at nas perez on social media coast to
coast and internationally doing red
carpets and coverage for folks like e
and right here at rotten tomatoes uh
thank you all so much for joining us
roxy and nas both champions in my book
of spirited debate keeping it clean
keeping the gloves on for the most part
for everybody here at binge battle and
rotten tomatoes including our insanely
talented engineer christian rubicaba i
am merely mark ellis saying thanks for
watching we'll see you next time and
enjoy the emmys
bring it on
you